[Musique]
le 11 mai prochain marquera la fin du
confinement et la réouverture des
services départementaux la reprise du
travail pour les agents sur site ainsi
que l'accueil du public se fera
désormais dans des conditions
particulières à commencer par
l'application d'une distanciation
physique de 1 m entre chaque personne
lorsque l'agent d'accueil sera à son
poste ici et si vous voulez il faudra là
aussi garder une distance d'un mètre
minimum avec l'usagé sachant qu'on
pourra accueillir un usager à la fois
donc là aussi on va prendre le m et on
s'aperçoit que pour obtenir cette
distance il va falloir matérialisée au
sol à l'aide d'une bande adhésive par
exemple cette distanciation minimale
samir var attias est conseillé
prévention département aujourd'hui ils
seront en territoire d'action sociale
nord de la collectivité pour contrôler
les bureaux et mettre en place les
dispositions qui assureront les
principes de précaution sanitaire pour
les conscient qu' on ne pourra plus
revenir le travail et faire comme avant
puisqu'il y aura de nouvelles
restrictions à respecter est donc une
sensibilisation devrait ainsi moment des
changes devrait se tenir entre
responsables élus
pour parler au sujet de ce serat seront
aussi d'avoir un bon levier les de
savoir qui est des mesures qui sont
prises pour nous protéger
ces mesures de précaution seront
complétées par la mise à disposition de
gants et de gels hydro alcooliques à
l'ensemble des agents de la collectivité
[Musique]